depuis quelques années il ya une
expérience que je fais quelque chose que
je fais en secret tous les jours et
certains jours à longueur de journée
pour ça j'ai pas besoin de m'isoler au
contraire c'est quelque chose que je
fais lorsque je m'adresse à quelqu'un
chaque fois que je le fais j'ai la
sensation de vivre même rien que le
temps d'une phrase le moment le plus
agréable que je pouvais vivre avec cette
personne à cet endroit
à cet instant juste en faisant ce que je
sais faire et comme c'est quelque chose
de très simple dans à peu près 15
minutes vous serez en mesure si vous le
voulez de faire ceci vous même dans
votre quotidien et sans que cela vous
coûte une minute de plus dans vos
journées juste en faisant un peu
différemment
quelque chose que nous faisons déjà à
longueur de journée il s'agit de notre
rapport au langage et notre rapport aux
autres via ce langage ce petit secret
cette expérience est en fait devenu très
rapidement une habitude
j'en ai parlé à quelques personnes et si
ça se passe pour vous comme pour ces
personnes et comme pour moi vous devriez
ressentir des effets immédiats de même
que votre entourage sans qu'il ait même
besoin de changer quoi que ce soit pour
cette raison on peut imaginer que plus
nous serons nombreux à prendre cette
petite habitude qui personnellement mais
très agréable plus l'impact sera
rapidement large
j'aimerais commencer par vous montrer
pourquoi il s'agit d'aller quelque peu à
contre-courant de certains de nos
automatismes et pour cela réouvrir avec
vous mes cahiers d'étudiants en
psychologie sociale avec en trame de
fond ma carrière d'artiste musicale
d'auteurs compositeurs et showman ma vie
familiale de couple et mon rôle de père
je m'exprime aujourd'hui en tant
qu'ingénieur amoureux des sciences
sociales et des sciences des origines et
fondements de l'être humain afin de
réaliser ensemble une petite
émulation préparatoire j'aimerais poser
sur la table deux concepts bien connu de
la psychologie sociale
le premier s'appelle biais d'auto
complaisance c'est ce qui fait par
exemple que lorsque nous vivons un
événement à satisfaisant pour nous par
exemple l'échec à un examen
nous serons plus à même d'expliquer ce
qui s'est passé par des causes externes
comme la difficulté de l'examen le temps
disponible le type de questions que si
nous avions peut-être réussi cet examen
auquel cas il sera plus facile pour nous
c'est une tendance de considérer que ce
qui nous arrive et les résultats de nos
propres actions et propres qualités
le deuxième concept c'est celui que les
chercheurs ont appelé erreur
fondamentale d'attribution c'est ce qui
fait par exemple que quand nous faisons
nos courses
le lendemain de l'annoncé du confinement
parce qu'on en a vraiment besoin et que
nous voyons une personne avec un caddie
rempli de paquets de papier toilette
qu'est-ce qu'on va se dire peut-être
qu'un grand nombre d'entre nous moi
compris on va se dire qu'elle égoïste
individualiste immorales non éthiques
peut-être même paranoïaque sans que nous
sachions que cette personne à cet
instant est en train de faire les
courses pour des personnes âgées de son
village et des environs
c'est cette difficulté qu'on a à
imaginer en tout cas en premier lieu que
les actions d'autrui peuvent être dus à
des causes externes de contexte
maintenant que les présentations sont
faites
j'aimerais faire avec vous cette
simulation on va prendre un
environnement clos comme une marmite
expérimentales ou un appartement en
plein confinement et on va y mettre deux
personnes on va rajouter un peu de
frustration
donc si on suit la logique qu'on a
paramétré juste avant il va certainement
se passer ceux ci
on va chercher un responsable et comme
tout ce qu'on voit c'est l'autre le
responsable c'est l'autre et on va lui
attribuer des caractéristiques internes
et telle quelle est la situation ça sera
certainement pas des qualités on va
peut-être lui dire en s'imaginant que la
personne va nous dire oui oui c'est vrai
tu as raison mais en fait ça se passe
jamais comme ça ça vous semble familier
cette situation parce que ce qu'on vient
de re synthétiser là c'est un élément
très présent de nos vie d'humain
civilisé ça s'appelle le conflit et la
définition que j'en fais et qui la
différencie du désaccord ou de la
frustration c'est qu'on a rajouté un
super ingrédients c'est super
ingrédients c'est l'idée qu'il y a un
bon et un mauvais un coupable un fautif
et ce super ingrédients s'appelle le
jugement
prenons maintenant la même situation
mais rajoutons une troisième personne
qui a lu ses propres objectifs sa propre
histoire ses propres valeurs et
peut-être que ce qui va se passer ça
pour une personne ou un groupe de
personnes mais eux ils ont peut-être
aussi de la frustration
donc ils vont chercher aussi un coupable
si on rajoute un troisième groupe qui a
lui aussi ses objectifs son histoire ses
valeurs
peut-être qu'il va se passer ceux ci et
si on en rajoute encore quelques autres
peut être cela et pourquoi pas ça ou ça
et encore ça
bon tout est allé un peu vite et la
géopolitique est évidemment une science
complexe est multifactoriel mais on peut
quand même imaginer qu'à partir du
moment où il existe l'idée d'un bon et
d'un méchant d'un coupable d'un mauvais
d'un fautif il est peut-être moins
difficile à ce moment-là d'appuyer sur
le bouton à ce moment-là d'enfoncer la
baïonnette et de malgré tout avoir une
bonne estime de soi mais le jugement est
nécessaire c'est un outil d'aidé à la
décision et nous a été vital parce que
nous sommes des champions de la survie
comme vous le savez ou des descendants
de champion de la survie si nous sommes
là de même que tous les êtres vivants en
dehors de cette salle et sur la terre
c'est que nos ancêtres depuis la
première cellule ont réussi à enfanter à
vivre suffisamment longtemps pour
enfanter jusqu'à nous et serait était
difficilement possible si on n'avait pas
attribué la qualité au loup d'être
dangereux à ce fruit d' être comestible
ou ce champignon d'être vénéneux et
d'inscrire sa dans notre encyclopédie
mentale personnel alors je ne sais pas
de quoi se parlaient les premiers hommes
mais on peut imaginer que par rapport à
aujourd'hui
les considérations était un peu plus
centré sur des questions de survie et de
la nécessité de s'activer
chaque jour intellectuellement et
physiquement pour trouver sa nourriture
est-ce qu'on aurait des considérations
du type oh là là j'ai croisé cette
personne elle est vraiment arrogante ou
en texto à celui laquelle radin ou sur
un clavier
les gens sont vraiment irrespectueux est
ce qu'elle est elle à ces considérations
je ne sais pas pas sûr et en plus ces
termes irrespectueux envers qui anvers
quoi ces termes sont pas précis à partir
de quel moment on décide de dire que
quelqu'un est respectueux à partir de
quel seuil
et puisqu'il est irrespectueux tout le
temps ou juste dans cette situation et
puis je pense que si on fait un test
tous ensemble
que je vous propose cinq définitions du
respect que je vous demande de les
évaluer selon lesquelles correspondent
pour vous le mieux
il est possible qu'on aboutisse pour un
même mot a finalement autant de formes
différentes que d'individus
pourtant on croit qu'on est tous
d'accord sur ce qu'elles veulent dire et
de comment les utiliser il ya donc
certains inconvénients à ces
qualificatifs mais il ya aussi deux
grands pouvoirs
le premier c'est la capacité que nous
confèrent ses mots à pouvoir hiérarchisé
et classer les individus entre eux ou
dans des catégories comme la catégorie
d'être moins fréquentables qu'un autre
d'être moins dignes d'être écouté d'être
moins dignes de commandes et d'être
moins dignes de recevoir des ressources
le deuxième pouvoir c'est que quand on
montre quelqu'un du doigt la critique
qu'on lui fait elle s'applique pas à
nous pour ce qui est de nos systèmes
biologiques
ils sont très anciens comme on le sait
très proches de ceux de plein de nos
cousins animaux et ya certaines choses
qu'on contrôle pas ou difficilement si
nous nous promenons dans la forêt que
nous entendant un bruit des motos nous
allons possiblement sursauter peut-être
partir en courant si nous regardons un
film de suspense sur notre écran de
téléphone
nous allons quand même avoir le coeur
qui s'accélère très probablement mais
par contre le fait de choisir quand on
sait les effets que ça peut avoir sur
notre interlocuteur est la vision que
peut avoir le groupe sur cette personne
là on a le pouvoir aussi de choisir si
on veut véritablement utilisé ces
qualificatifs et c'est en sac a résidé
mon expérience c'est regarder qu'elles
étaient toutes les choses qui
s'appliquait à cette situation de
jugement et on peut citer trois
composantes
la première c'est attribuer des
caractéristiques internes
la deuxième c'est le fait de le faire à
quelqu'un d'autre que nous la troisième
d'attribuer une responsabilité et j'ai
regardé quels étaient les éléments de
langage qui étaient des outils pour
servir ses fonctions et j'ai décidé
d'essayer de les enlever de mon langage
on a vu le rôle des adjectifs
qualificatifs subjectif mais il ya aussi
les vins
heures un peu de bienveillance ne ferait
pas de mal celui ci n'a pas de courage
il ya aussi les catégories psychologique
comportementale voir idéologie en
synthèse tout ce qu'on peut dire au
sujet de quelqu'un avec une grande
chance soit de se tromper soi que ce
qu'on est en train de dire englobe une
variété d'individus qui ont peut-être
des comportements beaucoup plus grave
que la personne dont on parle
autre chose au sujet duquel on a de
grandes chances de se tromper quand il
s'agit de l'autre ses affects ses
émotions ses pensées ses convictions ses
intentions le futur usage du futur
personnellement pas à prévoir mes
propres actions dur de prévoir celle
d'un autre usage de toujours tout le
temps à chaque fois et pour considérer
que l'autre est responsable il ya
évidemment des accusations explicites
mais pour ce qui est des choses subtiles
il ya par exemple les îles mahelma ça
m'a énervé agacé et tous ces adjectifs
verbaux qui termine en énervant agaçant
ces choses qui font que subtilement on
introduit l'idée que quelque chose
d'extérieur à une responsabilité sur
nous et comme l'objectif derrière c'est
aussi mené des études un peu plus
poussées notamment en termes
neurologiques et des questions de
neuroplasticité il a été vraiment
question de couper le rapport à ces
outils là par exemple dire c'est cool
dire c'est énervant
j'ai essayé de ne pas le dire et
d'éviter comme de me cacher derrière une
description d'autres choses que moi pour
s'écoule selon le contexte j'essayais
plutôt dire j'essaye plutôt de dire je
suis content que tu sois là le bilan de
l'expérience c'est qu'à aucun moment
quelqu'un m'a dit que je parlais
bizarrement ou que je faisais quelconque
expérience
la deuxième chose c'est que j'ai
toujours réussi à dire ce que je voulais
comme par contre des fois j'ai oublié de
faire l'expérience et que j'oubliais
le faire rigoureusement sa eu pour
avantage que je pouvais voir du coup ce
qui se passait dans un cas comme dans
l'autre et selon les différents degrés
d'applications pour faire cette
expérience et j'ai constaté que plus je
me consacrer pleinement à cette habitude
plus je sentais que j'étais plus précis
et mieux compris la deuxième chose c'est
que les décisions qui ressortait de ces
discussions m'avait l'air gagnante
gagnante et que les participants étaient
plus content de ces interactions qu'elle
était moins tendue moins longue et moins
tourner en rond alors on pourrait se
dire oui mais moi j'ai envie de ne pas
réfléchir quand je parle j'ai envie
d'être spontané naturel
c'est difficile de faire tout ça en fait
non non c'est pas compliqué s'agit juste
de commencer par jeu et de voir ce qui
se passe hélas ouvre tout un monde qu'on
a peut-être tendance à négliger qui est
celui des émotions des besoins des
demandes
ça c'est des notions qui sont très
présentes dans les travaux de marshall
rosenberg au sujet de la communication
non-violente sujet sur lequel je vous
invite à vous documenter si ça vous
intéresse
et j'ajouterais aussi l'expression d'une
intention j'aimerais faire ma conclusion
en mêlant les conseils que j'aurais aimé
avoir pour faire cette petite expérience
et que je vous donne maintenant avec ma
compréhension de sa philosophie
le premier c'est qu'il s'agit pas d'une
méthode pour arriver à convaincre
quelqu'un et l'amener sur notre point de
vue c'est plutôt quelque chose où chacun
présente ses besoins et ses limites et
duquel on essaye de sortir des solutions
qu'on n'aurait peut-être pas pu imaginer
au départ le deuxième c'est que si vous
souhaitez vous prêter à cette expérience
ce que je vous souhaite si quelqu'un en
face de vous parle différemment
il s'agit pas de le corriger au
contraire la notion d'empathie c'est
cette investigation dans laquelle on se
demande quel et l'émotion de cette
personne qu'elle et son besoin
quelle est sa demande et de vérifier ça
avec cette personne j'adorerais que vous
partagiez ces choses là et cette vidéo
mais pas s'il s'agit de faire une leçon
à quelqu'un notamment quelqu'un avec qui
vous êtes en conflit
enfin l'idée n'est pas de penser que
parce que ceux-ci à améliorer mon
bien-être que ça ferait de quelqu'un et
de quelqu'un qui se prêterait à cette
expérience comme vous une élite du
bien-être ou du savoir-être mes proches
savent très très très très bien à quel
point je ne suis pas parfait et juste ce
que je souhaite faire c'est faire de mon
mieux sur ce je vais quitter la scène je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté et je
vous dis au revoir
[Applaudissements]